that's missing
because it's like an attack on your
on it's just like a microgravity it's
like being wrong is the worst thing on
earth like being wrong is just a normal
part of life like you are gonna say
something so dude when i was in korea
right i don't know what happened to my
brain but i left it here and so when i
was in korea i was wrong about so much
[ __ ] and i kept catching myself and i
just mario looked at me she goes what's
going on i don't know i'm wrong about
everything like i would say stuff with
such confidence we were going somewhere
right in five four three two one what's
up everybody welcome to another episode
of the genius brain podcast we have
patrick dot t dot riley
the pink dick wonder
asian people have purple dicks
it looks like that weird orange and
purple uh popsicle that you get from the
ice cream man i don't know about jason
the chinese is black okay yeah nice is
pretty dark it's like a mummy dick
mine's like dead deceased gang green
dish
sarcastic it's gonna fall off
sarcophagus dick yeah that's what that's
and then we have nick the ear the purple
dick
weird taiwanese man you got purple dick
i got purple dick it's like purple as
[ __ ] yeah it's not like two purple but
it's like you know it's purple it's
purple a little dark though
if you didn't know that the asian people
have like different colored dicks it's
like the same color as mine yeah i
figured it was like a different color
but i didn't know i didn't know per i
wouldn't have said purple i was like
dark
purple
it's like somebody was choking it out
and they just never let go like an
eggplant like eggplant purple no not
that perfect like a dead corpse you know
like a dead body like have you seen the
lips on a dead corpse yeah is that what
it's like that is what it looks like but
like a little darker
a little bit darker i wish i was
exaggerating but but it kind of looks
like that kind of shout out to you know
the people that know that that's
probably why jason's dick looks like a
dead he looks like he's 100 dead dick
of somebody who drowned themselves in a
river
that's that is the uh
that is the color at the end of titanic
when leo is always yeah blue yeah that's
actually very accurate purple yeah that
is the color of it that's crazy show us
please i'll show you my [ __ ] instead
same color
blue mr manhattan dick dude no that's
too bright that's too bright it's neon
it's darker it's darker dude
did you see the series
i did i loved it the size of that man's
dong was ridiculous
it was so unnecessary unnecessary we
were watching the thing and all of a
sudden you just see this coke can just
dangling fat old dick from his waist it
was mr manhattan mr manhattan never seen
watchmen in the show on easter i haven't
seen the show i saw the first couple
episodes and uh tiff didn't watch it
with me so i'm gonna rewind the show
shits on the movie 100 the show is
phenomenal yeah watch watch it and you
see mr man's big old pepsi can dick it's
crazy how long that [ __ ] scared me that
dick was this dick in the movie yeah i
don't know if it's in the movie but in
the show i think his dick is in the
movie you would know gay boy
i watched all the movies with dickson
dude i was like trying to catch it
at the movie theater
it's not
sit down kid oh but when i was in south
korea apparently the whole world was
exploding and i got a lovely lovely text
from a few of my friends that were at
the chappelle stand-up show saying that
dave chappelle got [ __ ] attacked got
attacked
which is crazy just because recently
chris rock got the [ __ ] slapped out of
him by will smith by will smith so what
the [ __ ] is going on in this world is
everybody is there just like a target on
all comics like if you don't like what
people do like it's only black comics
that they're just going yeah why not
white comics yeah why not why isn't tom
segura getting sucked huh i don't know i
saw him post a video too right after the
will smith thing and he was like if
anyone comes up here he's like i'll bite
your [ __ ] face off
that's a strong deterrent i can't fight
but i'll bite your [ __ ] face this guy
that went up to to
assault dave chappelle
that was like a terrible attempt well
first of all michael when i saw that he
like jumped up he was like half asian
half black yeah he looks like the the
triple x tenchon the rapper honestly i
looks like that fool it honestly look
that was like one of day chappelle's
kids from the future and trying to stop
his dad yeah don't do any
more to tackle his dad
dude they folded that fool like a piece
of paper
like
the letter z like remember in sesame
street when they like are like we're
going to learn about the letter z
like put that dude up there somebody
literally put him in the arm bar and
snapped his arm buster [ __ ] his [ __ ]
up dude it was so bad they [ __ ]
folded him like an origami like
they literally turned him into another
human being dude i read something today
too that because of that they found
cause so what some [ __ ] they weren't
gonna they were gonna charge him with a
misdemeanor they weren't gonna prosecute
him because they were like oh it's a
misdemeanor because it's la i think what
it is is because dave's got the heat
from the trans community that they felt
like if they went after him
politicians are like [ __ ] like trans
community has a lot of power we don't
want to [ __ ] with that he's getting a
misdemeanor crazy because that was
assault and he had a knife on him but
anyways he had a knife on him he had
like a pistol that like it wasn't a gun
it like was like a knife so he had a
knife what is it acne cartoon what's
this [ __ ] did a flat come out of it like
what if stupid [ __ ] idiot but because
of this situation i was reading today uh
that
there would apparently he had like
stabbed his roommate or something and
they they didn't even know about it and
but all the heat they started looking
into them and they're like oh wait th
this full stab somebody they somehow
connected with the same gun
let them go and [ __ ]
they connect to another crime so now
they're like we're gonna charge them on
felonies but i don't to that case but i
don't think as to crystal where do you
find a gun knife and yeah why would you
have a gun which a gun is already lethal
why would you turn into a less lethal
weapon
what was he thinking he goes nah the gun
is not enough i gotta stab him how do
you get it in there i don't know because
how did he get a gun in there
he had good seats he was like from also
he paid the five hundred dollars it's
600. chappelle's shit's not cheap no he
paid like a g for that murder oh my god
maybe not a jeep but he paid
500 probably don't think he could have
traveled his way from the nosebleeds
no dude there's a gas security all over
the place that was one of the worst
types of history of tackles though yeah
it was terrible he like jumped at him i
was like come on bro yeah that [ __ ] was
bad dude
but he what so was it during the end of
his set or was in the beginning i don't
know i don't know where he was in a set
i think it was at the end but he that
full tackled him they beat the [ __ ] out
of his ass
chappelle gets up and just starts he's
like i think it was a trans woman or
something he like made a joke about that
yeah i was a trans man trans man
whatever he said and then everyone
started coming out and then chris rock
came out and was like was that will
smith like that was that clip
uh and apparently they probably had a
good time afterwards of course
there's no way dave chappelle is going
to sit there and then mope about that
[ __ ] no make jokes about of course
almost death near-death experience yeah
dude which is so [ __ ] dope too what
was the desired outcome of that guy
though like do people heard
[Laughter]
saving the day dude that's sick but i
don't understand too like what is what
is the logic behind this whole thing of
just people
okay a comic is making jokes that you're
offended by right but that's his job
he's gonna be on stage you're there at a
show watching what he does for a living
and then you go and try to kill him for
doing what his job is like i don't get
it not only that it's just like if you
don't like his [ __ ] just don't go oh
don't watch his [ __ ] that watch was
let's be real he was crazy yeah he had
to be crazy this morning
he's not thinking logically about this
[ __ ] he probably thought he was gonna
like get some clout by doing this man he
kind of did but also he's nuts yeah they
also need better security too yeah come
on even what is going on here that is
wild how the [ __ ] did he get up there
especially at a show like that hollywood
bowl it's netflix too wouldn't it yeah
but it's also the holly like the
hollywood bowl was like he's a big baby
venue huge venue be ready
yeah how come there's like no security
here like doing their [ __ ] job like
like dave
is literally an icon yeah like he dies
the whole it's like kobe dying yeah yeah
for reals for real so what's going on
here i don't get it protect dave
chappelle at all but the idea too like
people think it's okay just to start
attacking people now no
because while they're doing their job
will smith over here just setting
[ __ ] records now just giving people
the platform just to start slapping
people huh will smith you piece of [ __ ]
i love you you're actually my hero
we were very disappointed in you when
you did that yeah but that whole thing
just makes me always think too it's like
i always get worried for like the state
of comedy because
even the other day because when i'm on
the plane you know if i get wi-fi and
stuff i'm you know on social media to
kind of pass the time and i'm looking
through twitter
the things that get the most retweets is
somebody complaining about some type of
social injustice in society
and it's and look there are certain
things that make sense right and there's
a lot of things that you know you should
fight for
but literally the dumbest [ __ ] things
about your personal feelings about
personal issues are getting like 100k
retweets and there was like this tweet
about like
why is it okay for people to ask uh what
i'm doing uh at night how about
sometimes i'm just i just want to chill
at home
okay
how was this a big deal turn off your
phone people want to hang out with you
okay yeah that's what it is and then
this everybody going on a diatribe was
like yeah people don't respect my
personal space they think i have to go
out with them oh my god is this showing
a real issue people's first it's so soft
dude yeah so soft life's too good too it
really is honestly it really is one of
the most annoying things that i read to
when i was on the plane was somebody who
wrote a post that got a bunch of
retweets was like uh you don't know what
it's like to live in terror until you
live a day in the united states shut the
[ __ ] up bro the united states of america
this is where you live though let's go
to rwanda
[ __ ] genocide yeah the
what are you talking about doc dude i
literally just had a podcast with my
buddy sergio talking about his life in
colombia colombia where somebody tried
to kidnap him which is the reason why
his parents decided to move to the
states when they were both professors in
colombia and they started working like
like remedial jobs here because it was
safer yeah
bro
what are you talking about what
like i know there are very bad things
it's not to minimize how you feel about
the truck because there's been some
crazy [ __ ] that's happened of course
of course but when you make a statement
that's a wild statement to wake up in
the united states is to wake up in
terror we're like spoiled kids yeah
we're like spoiled kids that's really
what it is it's like we're spoiled
[ __ ] kids i mean not everybody
like there's people that like you
you grew up in watts like that's you're
dealing with some [ __ ] you know what i
mean but like for a lot of people i bet
you that [ __ ]
had a pretty if you're you're just
liking it pretty good if you're tweeting
it your life's probably yeah exactly i
had b new in on this podcast and she
told me this story which was kind of
funny but it's just the reality of the
situation she grew up in vietnam right
and so she grew up in vietnam and she
went to like east oakland which by the
way arguably probably worse than vietnam
on par yeah
and then she hears people complaining
about their life and he's oakland she
goes
you guys have a roof
she's like saying she's like amazed by
[ __ ] like that yeah i'm saying the small
things you have water you have air
conditioning what are you talking about
it's great here but that's her
perspective from growing up in vietnam
and moving into the states right so when
you have these statements and like
listen i'm not minimizing how people
feel about things that are happening
because i think that post was in
reflection to the shootings that have
been happening
but when you say a blanket statement
like to wake up in america to wake up in
terror it's like
yo you got to take a step back for a
second like this is a global platform
there's literally a war in ukraine and
russia right now where right [ __ ] kid
soldiers people are dying simply because
they're just ukrainian there have been
genocides there's people [ __ ]
starving they literally can't get food
anywhere at all compared to the states
where you walk into a homeless shelter
they'll give you a hot meal
we're we're kind of like comparing
apples and oranges here yeah but the
fact that that [ __ ] right there gets
like a hundred thousand retweets blows
my [ __ ] butt it's like i said it's
just like spoiled kid [ __ ] honestly
because it it you're right it's like if
anyone used any perspective you wouldn't
be saying some dumbass [ __ ] like that
but you can't say that too because now
you're minimizing how they feel which is
not the point you know
here's another thing about that so like
there are real issues and the whole
thing about like you can't minimize like
peop feelings for some reason like look
feelings are important but somehow they
became like the number one top priority
it's like
i yes your feelings are valid but also i
might i'm allowed to have the feelings
that say [ __ ] your feelings
you know like that's where we end the
podcast guys that's the message of the
day it's the tequila dude no wait but
i'm just saying that like it's it
feelings are important and we should
talk about everything why not yes of
course express yourself but it's not
like that can't supersede everything yo
100
like come on dude
everything we kind of come into this
part now too where i started to realize
that feelings matter more than facts now
that's what we're saying and there's a
good medium of both where you have to
empathize you have to understand the
human experience and all this other
stuff but then you also have to look at
facts and kind of find that good medium
where you understand what somebody's
going through but you have to
rationalize it within what's true yeah
right truth is also very very [ __ ]
important as much as your feelings are
but when you disregard the truth and it
only goes on feelings now we're now we
have a there's no foundation for any
type of argument it's always feelings
now i feel this way so my truth i hate
that phrase now yeah this is my truth
what the [ __ ] is my truth that doesn't
mean what is your truth what is it it
was like the hottest phrase like two
years ago this is my truth and it was
originally supposed to be a dope
statement to say like this is just
like this is how i see things in my
world and now it just became a thing of
like listen if i see it this way that
means it's right yeah exactly and that's
wrong that's right that's really the
worst way to go through life that's
wrong dude how do you live like that
it's just
insanity and then and then they'll turn
around [ __ ] on like a scientologist who
believes in aliens and they'll you know
be like but to that [ __ ] that's
his truth yeah who are you gonna tell
him that exactly zebulon isn't a real
[ __ ] place and it is though and to
tell you something join scientology
no lord l ron hubbard hell wrong what's
it called uh [ __ ] uh there's just
my buddy jason he does this thing called
um
this channel called jubilee and he does
this thing where he'll have two
competing sides uh talk to each other
and he had one where it was scientists
versus uh flat earthers oh nice and it
was the most frustrating thing i've ever
seen in my life i'm talking about these
people who are astronauts who have
dedicated their whole life to science
that has degrees phds their doctors for
crying [ __ ] out of space and these
people who are flat earthers
literally calling them stupid yeah they
go well you guys are dumb and everybody
in the comments are like how do you get
to a point where you look at somebody
who has studied something in and out
this is their job and career and you can
call them dumb
and all you do is scrub your ass at home
for 24 hours a day who the [ __ ] do you
think it's it's it's because feelings
have become like at some point those
flat earthers were told like it's okay
like don't tell them that they're wrong
don't tell like there needs to be a like
sometimes you're being a dumbass and
that's just for everybody humans i've
been a dumbass you've been you're always
a dumbass people have been done
i'm gonna [ __ ] you up after this podcast
the word
this is my baseline but you know what i
mean like
we all have moments where [ __ ] idiots
and it's actually a good thing for
someone to look at you and be like
you're being a [ __ ] idiot dude like
check yourself and be like oh [ __ ] maybe
i should check myself because that's
missing
because it's like an attack on your
on it's just like a microaggression it's
like being wrong worst thing on earth
like being wrong is just a normal part
of life like you are going to say
something so dude when i was in korea
right i don't know what happened to my
brain but i left it here and so when
when i was in korea i was wrong about so
much [ __ ] and i kept catching myself and
i just mario looked at me she goes
what's going on with you i don't know
i'm wrong about everything like i would
say stuff with such confidence we were
going somewhere right i'm like listen we
haven't been here and she goes we were
here the other day i was like no way
that store right there haven't seen it
and then as i'm walking by it i'm like i
remember that story i remember the story
that's what i did i looked at mario and
i was like i'm not saying anything
i just continue to walk until she was
like no i think we've been there okay i
was wrong all right i i was [ __ ]
wrong and she just i kept doing that
over and over and over but that's okay
yeah you just check your l's yeah that's
all it is even if it's like 17 times a
day it's just unless you're a flat
earther and you're an idiot because
their whole premise is like they think
everything around them it's a lie is a
lot everything you're you're being told
lives from nasa nasa doesn't know
anything this is a big conspiracy like
the moon landing was [ __ ] fake
why would it been why how what's the
purpose of it though why what is the
purpose of it being fake what does
anyone gain from the earth being flat
and also who gives a [ __ ] that's the big
question right yes what is the what is
the reason that nasa would be like the
earth is round what does that do for us
nobody thinks about that on the regular
basis are you going to check it
gains from that are you going to go to
the end of the earth to figure it out
what if it's the globe makers like
people that make globes like globes
they're like yeah we fooled them again
we're making so much money
more plaster around the globe than a
single disk
we've tripled our profits
they're the only
only [ __ ] that would benefit
from the lie that the world is a globe
they don't i don't think people that
make globes have that much power
they're they're probably really poor
right now
i'm just going to go on a limb nobody
even has a globe in their house anymore
get rid of that [ __ ] no one does but
it's kind of cool when you see one huh
you spin it i take it for a spin no you
touch it you just touch the mouth only
rich people have globes all right yeah
poor people don't have that [ __ ] don't
give a [ __ ] yeah you know what it sucks
right here by the way you see what's
going on the rest of the world
[ __ ] this [ __ ] every day
i remember when i was a kid people
didn't believe me that south korea was a
country and so i was in school and
probably i was in a dumb school but i
was like where are you from i'm korea
they're like
no you're not you're chinese i'm like no
i'm pretty sure i'm korean and they're
like nah dude you're from asia right i'm
like yeah you're chinese i started
doubting myself i'm like how am i trying
to stand up
and so we had to go to a globe and i
said no right there that's korean
they're like oh [ __ ] damn
this [ __ ] will spit like there's
chinese people in korea
this is like a little conversation in
second grade that's hilarious they made
me doubt i was from korea i had to find
a globe to point at it yeah nice that's
how dumb people are here the globe saved
the day but it's also second graders and
[ __ ] you know what i mean still it
doesn't matter how [ __ ] offensive i
am a [ __ ] you need to [ __ ] recognize
that you respect that you know dude yeah
i don't know man like this whole thing
of like like attacking people on stage i
i feel that this is a bad sign for kind
of the youth they feel like if i get
offended i need to just attack people
yeah no that that is kind of the message
and it's [ __ ] it's
it's insane like people just kind of
brush this under the rug like it's no
big deal what would you do if someone
came up to you and while you're doing
jokes on stage and they try to [ __ ]
attack you what would you do well i
would i would [ __ ] crack them like
what's your first what's your first move
well it depends on what they do like if
someone comes on stage and they're like
clearly like if they just walk up to me
and are like yo like i'mma [ __ ] you up
i'm swinging immediately once they're in
range
get the [ __ ] out of here you're crazy
you're a bully fighting dude you're
[ __ ] dog what do you mean
like loves violence yeah bro have you
seen have you it's not very peaceful of
you bro yeah but there was a clip uh
floating around like a few years ago uh
this these two there was a comic and a
heckler on stage and they're throwing
down they're like they're like squared
up this the video starts with them
squared up on stage like this and they
start swinging and the dude picks up the
i think the heckler picks up the mic
stand and starts swinging at him and
like the dude's dodging it but it was
chaos but these dudes were just
scrapping on stage it was [ __ ]
amazing there was oh that just reminds
me i saw this on the plane there was a a
stand-up comic i don't know who he is
but he was i forgot what the joke was
per se but he was doing in a in a crowd
for like hood-ass people he was the
white dude white dude yeah and the guy
was threatening to like kill him and he
was just kind of riffing off it's a
white dude in a white sweater tall guy
yeah yeah i think i know yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's a white name's johnny
mitchell he was like yeah i met him yeah
yeah he was just riffing off these guys
like literally threatening him and one
guy goes up on stage he tries to attack
him and like they kind of have this
weird he like kind of whiplashes or
whatever yeah he's like he goes i
[ __ ] kill you right now dude he goes
really are you
that's the same place where the dude
pulled out a gun when mike tyson was
there
[Music]
that place is nuts dude where is that
every time i see a video with that
background it's like called sunset
sunset something and it's got the little
glittery gold in the back in l.a i think
it's in hollywood it's like i think it's
a rooftop or something but anyways
whenever i see that background i'm like
some shit's cracking off for sure
so it's the same why do people perform
there dude
that guy literally was going to [ __ ]
kill some dude i would perform there to
be honest he was like oh he was like you
it's like i've been he was like talking
about him he's like i've been in jail or
something like that and he's like okay
cool like he goes what are you scared he
goes yeah i'm scared he's like of course
i'm scared you went to jail what the
[ __ ] are you talking about yeah and the
guy he's like roasting this dude which
obviously as a you know veteran comic he
probably is going to do that of course
and he's
making me laugh i'm giggling yeah yeah
and all of a sudden this guy thinks says
it's okay to [ __ ] go ahead and text
crazy why why is that okay you're at a
comedy show
how does that make sense what are you
doing dog what are you doing there don't
go to comedy shows i don't understand it
like make this make sense to me no yeah
comics need to train men
there you go that's your new clientele
comics honestly mostly people i train
are kind of comedians but i wonder too
it's like do you think somebody would
have ran up on stage at joe rogan no
[ __ ] no joe rogan would have choked you
out immediately those guys that were
talking to that white guy they probably
thought they could beat this fool's ass
yeah they thought that they could like
intimidate him to stop talking [ __ ] yeah
and it kind of worked when i realized
that someone i don't like either like if
you're such a tough dude you should go
after people who can actually do some
[ __ ] about it well they're bullies yeah
exactly that's the thing they're bullies
and that's what i'm saying like you know
we had this previous podcast we're
talking about brendan but uh brian
callan and that's like the whole brine
counting which is why i disliked it so
much like he thought that he could talk
to bobby lee that way because he's the
goofy
you know bobby lee pacifists you know
very pacifist not gonna clap back yeah
and he thought that he could [ __ ]
bully him yeah
it just it sits wrong with me because
it's like okay brian would you have
let's say you found out that joe rogan
was talking [ __ ] about you would you
have popped off and threatened uh joe
rogan saying listen i know joe rogan
hey joe rogan i know joe rogan's like he
will cancel you have joe rogan
like was he going to do that to joe
rogan probably not but he thought he
could do that to bobby yeah which is so
unfair and strong yeah and he didn't
realize that [ __ ] collide was a
psychopath
that's crazy she wants that smoke yeah
she wants to see ready for it she's
ready for all that type of [ __ ] i said
this whole idea too it's like you know
and brian count has openly said too i
hate bullies you're a bully bro
you're a bully the [ __ ] are you talking
about so i always wondered too and i
said in the previous one what the [ __ ]
did he go through
like what i want to know his background
what kind of trauma you went through
brian you bullied him like what did he
go through in his whole life for him to
always feel that he has to be a tough
guy even though you're a comic being a
tough guy comic does absolutely nothing
for you yeah it's like come on against
the ball
yeah
not just you're among comics are not
tough
dudes
like it's not a tough bunch of
[ __ ] it's like that's not
impressive yeah to be a tough guy it's
like yeah all these comics are nerds and
[ __ ] like who cares you know like who
gives a [ __ ] have you ever seen did you
guys ever get to see charlie murphy
perform
no i went to one of his stand-up
specials not specials but one of uh his
uh stand-ups say something i only
laughed cause i was so scared of him
yeah i felt like i had to laugh or he
was gonna kill me
and i gotta tell you i did not find him
funny
i just laughed though yeah
he started to stand up later in his
career right like he did chappelle first
and then he kind of started doing stand
up yeah i think like eddie was the one
that kind of you know told him to do
stand-up and you know like i said he's
passed away i still think he's [ __ ]
hilarious i mean his his dave chappelle
was amazing oh [ __ ] funny dude but
that's why i wanted to go watch him uh
do stand-up and i you know it wasn't
that funny to me he was new yeah but he
was definitely i don't know his presence
is so scary it's hard to laugh at
somebody that's [ __ ] intimidating you
through for a whole set
he looks like a he looks like he's done
[ __ ] in his life like he has okay well
there it is
i've heard some crazy stories about him
while the game that's [ __ ] wild like
what yes i don't know i don't remember
the specifics but i remember him like i
think it was him telling or i don't know
if it was him or somebody talking about
him but
stories involved i think it was him on
like on radios he was like but he was
very vague about it he was like i can't
go into the details because obviously
it's some incriminating [ __ ] he's like
but understand like it almost got there
and like that's all i have to say sir
guns might have been involved but we
squashed it and thankfully we're both
here alive
it was something like that where it was
like that's real tough okay like it was
someone starts being vague i can't tell
you details it's like okay someone was
about to get shot in the [ __ ] head
and that's very different and it was
very very different yeah for sure that
yeah too and like i think like with um
with brian too when i always hear his
like tough guy stuff like i said it was
very entertaining at first and now it's
just a weird part of his psyche because
there's also this really uncomfortable
clip of brendan's shop and have you seen
it yeah just going at it oh no oh i
fight it was something like that along
those lines of like yeah he was saying
like you've never been in a fight and
that's what brendan schaub is saying to
brian
yeah and he gets like really worked up
like uncharacteristically oh really yeah
you don't you don't know me you don't
know how many street fights i've been in
i go i've been in more street fights
than you have and then brendan's like oh
you've been in more street fights than i
have i i don't think that's true at all
i've been in a lot of street fights this
sound is so stupid yeah yeah why would i
say that to brendan shot yeah that's
supposed to be entertaining what are you
what are you [ __ ] dick measuring
street fights for what are you trying to
prove yeah who cares the thing is is
like that i mean it's like cliche but
it's like yeah you're right like people
that are actually tough aren't about it
don't need to talk about it you know
it's like that loud barking [ __ ] like
why and you're talking to a [ __ ] like
said spider a heavyweight
top 10 usb ufc knocked out mirko yeah
like like what the [ __ ] how are you
gonna say that you're tougher than the
guy that literally fought one of my
favorite fighters of all time and
knocked them out god down with no guerra
for real a legend even though he lost he
he still was in the ring fighting a
legend yeah dude all the guys he fought
were scary as [ __ ] travis brown at the
time when he found him was scariest
[ __ ] division [ __ ] his ass up yeah
that's bad he [ __ ] his ass actually
made me feel good but it does seem like
a thing like themed for him right where
he just keeps talking about like i'm a
tough guy
[Laughter]
just just for the other podcast no but
like that's that's the thing too like
this whole like pseudo tough guy stuff
is very audited you can kind of smell it
on people you can yeah and i think with
with brian when it was a joke at first
it was very very fun but once it started
becoming really serious it's not funny
anymore i always thought it was a joke i
didn't know it was serious that is
that's that is kind of weird it's like
what oh you really think that why is it
that everybody in that circle too is
going through their cancel phases
crystalia had his cancelled face brian
callum has his cancelled face now
brendan schaub is going through it like
what the [ __ ] is it about that specific
comic group that they're always in some
[ __ ] i think i think part of it is like
joe rogan like because they're like when
he had bernie sanders on like there was
like he was starting to have like some
influence that's when [ __ ] started
cracking off with crystalia and like
joey diaz had a moment where like
because he said that he like made a girl
suck his dick for stage time at the
comedy store or whatever like little
things like that started happening so i
think it's more
based on the ripple like look these guys
aren't perfect they're comics you know
what i mean they're wild [ __ ] dudes
but i think it has to do with the joe
rogan's influence more than it does like
that and they have they have a lot to
lose this this this though with brenton
schaub i think is not that i think i
think this is different i think this is
they just somehow for whatever reason
like popped us up out of nowhere on
themselves
yeah i mean like it's like yeah cause
he's arguing with his peers you know
like people that he's like colleagues
with it's not like the internet yeah
like it wasn't it was yeah they just
they created the situation out of
nothing but with crystalia i remember
there was something like because even
like so elon musk for example now like
he bought twitter and then he made that
post where he's like yo i used to always
vote democrat but like they've become
the party division i'm going republican
today there's a story now about how he
like exposed himself to some girl
uh and paid her off 250 thousand dollars
and even before he was like watch them
come after me now and literally today
now there's this post about so like
whenever someone bernie sanders did no
elon no elon musk oh that'd be way
funnier that'd be so much funny it was
bernie let's let's play that scenario
socialism is wrong but be sure your dick
is okay with his gloves and sitting in
the chair like hey he's just trying to
share man he doesn't share a stone he
goes what's wrong with a little rape pup
but socialism evil
he's just trying to share it dude he's
just trying to share it so democratic
social
[ __ ] showed his dangling well that's
the story but but it comes after i mean
like him buying twitter and then saying
that and then he literally post he's
like watch them come after me puts like
a little popcorn emoji and then today
there's like a story like this girl got
paid off because he showed him his dick
or whatever it's being weaponized now
but i'm just saying like they will if
somebody gets too big and they start
like they can kind of play with the
narrative a little bit
the machine
will will go after him
that's what it looks like but but this
brendan shop [ __ ] i think that's not
what's going on i think they just
talking
out of the way
i don't know what's going on there that
but it has nothing to do with that i
don't think i think that's just his own
dumb [ __ ] i don't know what i feel like
once you become a certain amount of
famous like you're always just going to
be a target now because people are going
to dig up something about you right for
sure and the weird thing is too is like
when the public sees bad things about
that people have done it's like stuff
that you've probably done yourself but
the only difference is that you're not a
celebrity yep yeah and it feels good to
be like [ __ ] on somebody and even though
you've done [ __ ] up things it just for
some people for people that are i think
weaker minded it just feels good to [ __ ]
on somebody else and you make you forget
about your life somebody there was this
asian kid that kind of went after uh
this white girl who wore this like
chinese dress
and for her junior prom saying it's like
cultural appropriation also the [ __ ]
okay all this other stuff right and then
literally somebody just went through his
twitter and he's calling black people to
edward with the hard r
saying that's what i'm saying which yeah
way worse you put that on twitter yeah
it's like what the [ __ ] was this guy
doing yeah that's just a clear example
he's culturally appropriating white
culture
hey man that's your caller
my [ __ ] that's our thing dude
back off that's ours
pride
the [ __ ] out of here with my racism dude
that feels such an appropriate right
that's an appropriate i think that's the
most outlandish that's what these people
that's what a lot of these kids are like
they always love to just tear somebody
down knowing that they have
imperfections themselves yeah it's not
going to make you a better person the
loudest guy that's trying to make it
seem like he's a good person is
definitely the biggest piece of [ __ ]
dude a hundred percent all the time the
guy that's always like i'm not racist
and then wants to tear this person down
for sure racist dude my favorite [ __ ]
phrase is this i don't see color oh shut
up
that means you're racist that means you
treat black people differently when
you're around them yeah or you trade
other races completely different oh we
all see color yeah we a hundred percent
do
is that that's not an issue yeah that's
it's never an issue to see
different cultures and different
ethnicities and races that's not a
[ __ ] problem it's what you do with it
that's the issue yeah the [ __ ] you mean
you don't see color dude get the [ __ ]
outta here with that [ __ ] i don't see
color whatsoever like really i'm color
blind for reals no literally
i don't know what color your shirt is
it's green and red
oh okay my bad bro
i'm actually blind i don't see [ __ ]
that's not a stick
i was trashing this guy for an hour
my buddy ed too this is the funny [ __ ]
that he ever did he was at a thai
restaurant
and um there was this dude like in the
corner being all cool as [ __ ] wearing
sunglasses in in the in the restaurant
and this fool is just going oh there's
[ __ ] guys in l.a one of the stupidest
[ __ ] sunglasses
i do that all the time
[ __ ] he can't [ __ ] pour his own
sauces and economists but he has his
lady doing it for him
[Laughter]
he's talking bad [ __ ]
and this fool gets up
[ __ ] mortified he was like i was like
bro you're going to hell dude you
literally talk [ __ ] about a blind dude
for an hour that's hilarious that's so
funny the [ __ ] hilarious that's
amazing
that's a hella
he wasn't hella mad but i told that
story to like martin joe they turned
into a sketch but it was his story
he was like a little bad about that
that's like [ __ ] funny that's funny
that's funny yeah hey you messed up it's
not good it's okay i've done that you
pre-judged some people you preach that
pre-judging is a normal thing to do
that's just [ __ ] crazy though i can't
believe this fool was just [ __ ] talking
to a blind dude that's a [ __ ] cool la
guy he probably wasn't acting that blind
though you know i was like some blind
people are like real blind he was
probably just like a real suave
[ __ ] who just happened to be
blind yeah how does his lady be taking
his cigarette backwards
it's not lighting
here the filter's being lit up
look at this guy smoking a cigarette
backwards oh so different
he thinks he's so cool [ __ ] cool dude
why don't you make eye contact with
somebody when you talk to them this
one's always stared off somewhere
[Laughter]
other i'm that guy dude i'd be a [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] like oh my god
that's so good that's my new year's goal
though just top uh to stop talking [ __ ]
so much
why do you feel like you talk so much
[ __ ]
i don't know feels good you know like in
what scenarios do you feel like
i think people feel like i talk a lot of
[ __ ] but the difference is i always say
talking [ __ ] is different if i've
already said it to their face
if i said it to their face and i say it
behind their backs and i say it in
public it's all the same yeah they know
this yeah like you know i don't like you
like i've done this multiple times like
even in high school it was like that did
you guys ever do well in school i did
yeah i did get in school actually for
real yeah because i was good at like i
would [ __ ] around but when in class i
could listen and i would like i was good
at figuring out i knew by the way they
were talking what was going to be on the
test and i would write i i was just good
at that and then i would cram before
tests and i have a good memory gpa when
you graduated like three point seven or
something [ __ ] guys and he went to a
good school what a [ __ ] nerd bro what
else you do i was a nerd rolly back to
[ __ ]
bro in elementary school i had a rolling
bag
that's what i love your perfect ass
posture dude yeah that's only measures
but yeah no i i i don't know i was able
to do it i don't know what the crap 3.7
you ain't no comic
i crammed honestly in retrospect i wish
i knew that high school really doesn't
matter that much i would have gone i
would have [ __ ] around so much more
but i was so afraid of like the
consequences of like not graduating in
high school i went to college yeah which
college uh santa barbara you see santa
barbara what the [ __ ] this is
you graduate i graduated yeah bitch-ass
[ __ ]
i dropped out [ __ ] like a rumor
you graduated too hot [ __ ] come on yeah
it took me like eight years though no
like a real man i went to community
college and i was like i got to get my
[ __ ] together yo
i was like it was just hard for me to
get classes because my major was
sciences but yeah i'm the dumbest one in
this [ __ ] north region she went to
northridge i went to northridge for two
years that she was cool too but the
whole time i [ __ ] hated school dog
i would get some professors because look
i knew i was in kinesiology right and i
would get some professors fake news go
ahead no for real some of it really is a
[ __ ] sham like the only classes i
really liked was like exercise
physiology because it was like oh this
is like actual science and that was the
one time i was like oh i think i liked
science like i figured it out like i
liked anatomy i like all that [ __ ] but i
had this one like most of my professors
were all full of [ __ ]
like a lot of them didn't know what the
[ __ ] they were talking about well they
would just go in there and they would
just phone it in i had one class where
you had to juggle for the final bro
you had to learn how to juggle college
and this was like a motor development
skills class and it's like teaching you
how to like learn skills
and the whole time i was like bro i'm
commuting
monday through friday to this [ __ ]
class where the final is juggling or
as an alternative cup stacking
and like i was like
i'm not going to juggle first i'm going
with the cup stacking easy did i just
pay dog that's
that's what i'm saying thousand dollars
to learn how to juggle after this go get
a job
i would i would i went to the final and
it was like you had to show the
professor
juggling with three balls
and then i was like
i didn't practice because i was like
[ __ ] that so i go up to him and i like
[ __ ] up consistently yeah and then he
gives me a b
why don't you just double leg his ass
and beat his ass
like with the audacity wow and he knew
it was [ __ ] he looked at me like
sorry bro this is just that's the
curriculum that's the stage this was one
of the classes like it was just and it
was like my first year
like my junior year in college
and i just was like this is such a sham
bro
and it was like i learned nothing
i learned nothing and you got a b you
dropped the balls and got a b oh bro i
didn't even try to jump i was like i
looked at him like
can't do it what do you want me to do
bro this is crazy you know this is
ridiculous i wish i would have [ __ ]
taken that class i [ __ ] took stupid
[ __ ] i thought it was econ uh biz major
also sounds like it was legitimate
actually those are good things yeah yeah
yeah
i i did really bad because they were
teaching me real [ __ ]
but juggling cup stacking if i knew i
had that class i would have been super
happy dude you could really juggle it's
like you bet i want this a dude wait how
did you have to stack the cups like you
got to make a pyramid those professional
cup stackers yes you would have to do
like a segment of that
why
just to prove that you learned the skill
and you could practice it i'm like i'm
not gonna wait i'm not gonna invest my
time on this [ __ ] dude the class was how
to learn a skill it was the basics of
like motor development which is like a
fancy word of just like learning skills
that's what it was
and it was just like trying to reverse
engineer how to teach exactly it's all
nonsense it's nonsense
wow you know what the most annoying
thing about college was like if you
transferred to school like let's say you
were at a university right and you took
this obscure class that credit means
nothing yeah i i took this class
modern and political uh repression in
modern china
there is no other class anywhere for
that too long ago and i had to retake it
i was like cool i'll just retake it so i
can redo my gpa i go to i go to a
different university they're like we
don't have this class you're just stuck
with this f i'm like what the [ __ ] how
am i supposed to undo this f because
it's just very specific i still have the
book for that course oh dumb dude it's
so [ __ ] dumb it really did we should
do a podcast reading from that textbook
oh and teaching let me tell you
something i learned nothing let it live
i just knew that chinese people have it
bad
hey you got an a now yeah i'm like hey
man it sucks to be you guys and they're
like like a plus a plus you're good
don't worry don't worry
just juggle the ball a plus [ __ ] you guy
what was the most pointless class you've
taken i had a few actually so what
what's your major i started film film
and media studies which okay that's
insulting
i started filming
but the problem was is that most of it
was theory-based so like i like i
basically am a professional audience
member like i'm really good at watching
movies and like dissecting ideology
[ __ ] like that you should do a
filmmaker with david you production
classes which were dope and i did learn
like how to add edit and do audio stuff
like that
um
most point i took a few pointless
classes one was a porn class actually
but this is kind of entertaining so the
latest is actually on purpose huh i did
yeah because i was like there's a porn
class like what the [ __ ] is this yeah so
we had a big theater
with all those people
david that this is what i thought i
thought it was gonna be cool i'm gonna
be jerking off it's gonna be sick dude
we watched we watched one normal like
heterosexual porno like where it was
like it was called deep throat it's like
the the history so in the 70s when porn
there used to be like porn theaters or
you should be like people would like for
we're gonna go out to the movies tonight
we're gonna watch an adult film and like
you could go it was like a thing an
outing that couples and obviously
weirdos would go to and
deep throat was like the first major
uh like one of the first blockbuster
pornos and the story was that this lady
had a [ __ ] at the back of her throat and
she kept going to these doctors and
she's like i don't i gotta click [ __ ] in
my throat and the doctor be like i got
just the solution for you
and he would shovel was the solution he
would shove his dick
in the back of her throat and like come
and then be like ah you gotta talk to my
colleague he's gonna help you out and
it's it was just that was the movie of
horton just getting face [ __ ] by
everybody
it was impressive though because she
could deep throat she like didn't have a
gag reflex it was like this is the
beginning of that stuff right so we
watched we heard the history of that
blah blah
all the other pornos were like crazy
[ __ ] like
like weird fetish stuff
uh like we watched we watched like a gay
porn one time so it's this big ass
theaters like state of the art it's
called boys in the sand i would have
failed immediately dude boys in the sand
and it's like
now we're in a room i actually kind of i
was laughing because i was just watching
every like everyone else
but there's dudes just getting
[ __ ] hard 50 like feet screaming
just stick ass boot like
ass oh billy yeah [ __ ] me my ass
i'm looking at dudes there's dudes like
watching it but they're like they're
like
[Laughter]
they're like
they're just like this i need to pass
i need this
we but we that so
we watched like i remember there was one
like the first pornos we watched some of
the first pornos ever they were black
and white like french movies and there's
i i remember this vividly because they
[ __ ] tracked me up
there's like so it's like it's like when
they would there was no word so they
played a piano in the background
and there's this guy like just [ __ ]
this girl in the meadow or something
right
it's like got that weird like kind of
like you think they sped up the footage
kind of moving into it
uh and this guy like their [ __ ] dog
this podcast is brought to you by better
help my friends life can be overwhelming
and many people are burned out without
even knowing it and that could be you
are you feeling unmotivated or helpless
or trapped i have been talking about
better betterhelp and they have been
such a good sponsor to us because i use
it and a lot of you have used better
help if you've heard this ad before and
you haven't tried better help or any
type of online therapy better help might
be the one for you better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be messed
with the therapist in under 48 hours
once again i've been using betterhelp
for a long time and let me tell you
something i got better help in my back
pocket because let me tell you something
my friends that boy got problems and
that boy is me let's start feeling
better together my friends genius brain
lifters get ten percent off their first
month at betterhelp.com genius that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash genius style for a while
and then this guy comes out of the
bushes like another guy and he's like
kind of like he as they're [ __ ] he's
like inspecting and it's like
and then like a letter like letters will
pop up and say oh no you know like super
the guy's like looking he looks at the
girl he looks the guy looks at the girl
and then he takes his pants down and he
starts he puts it in the guy's ass so
the guy's [ __ ] the girl and he puts
it in his ass and like gets like
i saw like 30 pumps like ding ding
and then he like backs up and then he's
like all right i'm gonna go [ __ ] her
face now and he starts like danny d puts
his dick in her mouth and then he put it
in his ass and then he goes back first
atm on footage and then
he goes back to the guy and like goes in
for a second impressive kind of puts it
in and the guy like [ __ ] the girl is
kind of like ah and then he kind of like
he's like nah he's like no no more he's
like you can't you see him be like nah
no you [ __ ] me 30 pumps
32 maybe but like i'm out now yeah yeah
and then
and then he goes back to the girl's face
and then it just cut to
uh some other weirdo scene it was the
weirdest [ __ ] class i've ever taken
in my life learned nothing watched weird
porn they would have porn stars come in
and talk to us which is kind of
entertaining
other than that don't don't know why
that's a class
made no sense see college can be a sham
yo
it really can be it could be a [ __ ]
rapper the teacher spin on it was that
it was like a feminist porno class
literally learned nothing about
women how this was good for women or
what i just watched a lot of weird [ __ ]
i feel like the professor just wanted he
just has a camera recording everybody's
reaction to watching gay porn he's just
cracking the [ __ ] up after just
dude
[ __ ] were uncomfortable dude
and i was laughing i'll tell you this
even when i do watch porn and then
there's like it switches over to the
guy's face my dick goes limp yeah why
are you showing his face i don't like
when to show you the passion can i just
say this everybody who is a porn
director i don't watch porn that much
anymore but what i do i just would would
request
nobody needs to see the guy do this
nowhere right before he's about to go we
know what his face looks like yeah when
a guy watches porn right we're imagining
that we are there yeah i don't need to
see his face yeah
immediately also the guy stop dirty
talking so much be quiet shut the [ __ ]
up dude no more talking shut up you like
that yeah yeah baby oh yeah you look
daddy does that do you like dude shut up
also girls
shut up
shut up yeah i don't
like that
first of all nobody talks like this yeah
stop it i hate this so much mute be a
professional be a professional all right
[ __ ] be a professional when's the last
time you actually really had sex for fun
yeah right go back to those days go back
to those days it's just disgusting yeah
i hate it it's a bit much that can't be
the norm okay because that's gonna be
the baseline some people are gonna think
that's normal well you know the weird
thing about like porno now it's so hyper
accessible like people don't understand
how hard it was to get porn when i was
younger i had to hit up a contact of
this dude that could get it downloaded
somewhere that had a vhs somewhere and
then we had to hide that [ __ ]
[ __ ] would tear pages out of
like [ __ ] playboys and sell them for
a quarter
say hey bro you trying to get that dick
card later or what
take turns with the same piece of paper
50 cents
how about 35. yeah i brought you a
customer
they slide over the piece of paper i
look at it i'm like hey man she coming
up her tits yeah that's what 35 gets you
you should have known about that [ __ ]
homie if you want that 50 cent [ __ ] i
got you bro slice it over it's full 10 i
don't see [ __ ] just a dollar
this guy's good this guy's next you know
i used three dollars damn
and i just have a collection of four
torn pages
they got you it was hard man like i
would specifically remember to dog i had
this neighbor who lived across my street
his name was sam
and his internet was a little faster
than mine and the first time i ever
watched porn was over at his house and i
just remember on this little 56k modem
it would just be bait
and we would just sit there for five
minutes waiting for the full picture to
load and it would finally happen i'm
like wow this is great do you guys
remember the first porno you actually
watched as like a young child i don't
know the video i don't know the first
sure and i remember i got freaked out
when i saw
a girl sucking dick because i didn't
want to see a guy's dick and you're like
oh that was common i used to cover the
guys yeah and it would freak me the [ __ ]
out so i only
i only liked you
because i could see naked ladies but
every time i saw a guy it would it would
like make me feel weird and i turned out
i'm gay
that weird like that but it would just
it would like make my dick soft i'm like
oh god damn it for me it was because
like i watched it like i would watch
porn with my buddies which is kind of
gay but like
it was like all kind of we were like we
were like
like like trying to like prove to each
other that we were not gonna look at it
dude
but you end up playing like whack-a-mole
because the camera angles change it
changes and so you have to like you're
i'm actually more focused on this guy's
dick than anything else in the video uh
but yeah i remember doing that too and
now it's like [ __ ] whatever well now
he's looking like that now
it's like wait i'm that guy i have a 10
inch dick this is pretty awesome yeah
and i'm ripped that's sick we had a
conversation on jk news about this years
ago they're like how do you guys [ __ ]
watch porn when you're literally seeing
a dick in there isn't that isn't that
considered kind of gay or like no no no
no we are the guy yeah i'm the guy i'm
i'm i'm going suave i'm the star of the
movie yeah and i'm having sex with this
lucious woman listen
you know what's wild is like when they
start doing like i'll i'll be like
sometimes like a doodle spit in a girl's
face or something and i'll just like
like i'll just it'll take i'll be like
damn this is rude yeah that's wild
that's rude i don't like that okay let's
just get on the fish hooking bro like
hey what is that about that's also
unnecessary yeah you got her [ __ ]
damn have you ever been with a girl that
asked you to hit them no
no not like and not hit them no that
[ __ ] is so [ __ ] weird it's not and
what is that such like a what is be
specific when you say hit me yeah right
i don't mean like slapping on the ass
i'm talking about this yeah this girl
actually imagine it's this girl
elbow to slap the living piece out of
her mouth
and it's weird because
you know when somebody says these type
of things i first of all i'd never
experienced that i didn't know what the
[ __ ] to do with it how do you respond to
that well you have to slap them because
they're literally getting turned on by
the [ __ ] you're not going to be the guy
that's going to just ruin the moment
i remember when i first slapped her
right did you do a feeler did the
people's elbow it was like it was like
this
i went like this i went
like that and she legit said to me i
just remember the [ __ ] she goes you
[ __ ] [ __ ] slap me harder my dick
went soft immediately yeah and she's
like what happened
you called me a [ __ ] yeah and i'm like
i can't i'm not hey give me a heads up
that's wild tell me like hey i like this
type of [ __ ] don't just spring it up on
me [ __ ] like what the [ __ ] we at that
time we hooked up twice this never
happened before that's crazy so she
never taught me this [ __ ] on number two
that's pretty wild so you know we tried
doing it again and let me tell you
something i was irritated
the [ __ ] out of him
[Music]
i slapped this girl to an oblivion and
what was her reaction she loved it she
came she loved it yeah i did not like it
though that's weird i didn't like it
yeah cause you don't you don't want to
just beat the [ __ ] out of women yeah
like my my fingers were hot wow and i
felt bad but yeah i [ __ ] loved it
yeah i'm like listen this is some weird
[ __ ] that's a slippery i don't care if
it turns you on it it's turning me off
i'm not yeah i'm not trying to beat this
[ __ ] honestly i just want to have sex i
don't want to [ __ ] assault somebody
it's so much work what's going on it's
also a lot of work dude yeah it's like
go ahead just [ __ ] just do it like a
[ __ ] speed bag
like tie my tits in the knot and hang me
from it and find me damn [ __ ]
i don't know about them [ __ ] marvin
gaye and have sex weird [ __ ] dude like
she liked me she's like um what do we
call that [ __ ] the [ __ ] the change
[ __ ] what do you call that stuff bdsm
yeah i don't finally [ __ ] with that [ __ ]
me neither that's weird yeah it's too
much extra stuff it's too much work
let's see what is it basic let's keep it
fundamental you know i don't want to be
hitting anybody dude also i don't want
to be hit i've had girls try to choke me
and i was like i don't want to feel pain
at all right now like literally in the
middle they try to just choke you out
yeah like they'll try to choke me or
like do and it's like i or like hard
scratches it's like i
i don't want to feel pain right now like
this is i just want pleasure no pain
don't pull my hair what
this she just starts braiding your hair
it just hurts it hurts fine you could
break my hair she's got the rat tail
comb out i'm sorry
bro that's kind of like a sick ass brain
start playing with it
it's all itchy and [ __ ]
i don't know that's just not i don't get
it but yeah i'm not i'm with you i don't
mind if they tell me to like choke them
a little bit i'm okay but i can't
practice you know standard practice
this little little
that's generally like the book seems
well alive the book's been updated
that's standard practice standard
practice little slap on the ass yeah do
a feeler though slap
you know just place it and then see what
happens place what they do stick a dick
in the nostril and just [ __ ] swap
them i'm okay with that
yeah
you guys don't do that you guys don't do
the pcr [ __ ]
you're positive for covet and aids yeah
dude you guys don't do anti-gen [ __ ]
dude
i'm not really down with the coveted
thing i just get it out of the door
yeah yeah you like that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's right you got the [ __ ] vid huh
you got it you got it well guys that
wraps up this episode
yeah we got uh patrick.t dot riley you
can follow him on instagram he's doing
the stand up telling jokes [ __ ]
he's out here
[ __ ] on people taking away his
racist powers
right
that admiral stuff is his peoples yeah
all right don't you try to take it now
that's cultural appropriate we got nick
the ear over here being a jiu jitsu
coach you could go ahead and sign up for
his classes see him online he got some
online training stuff he's doing what
he's doing man out here in the streets
sucking that dick relentless dude what
i'm saying all teeth ding dong no scene
full eye contact right right that's
right lips wraps the ass cheeks spreads
it open helps you fart without making a
noise because the butt cheeks are the
part that make the noise people don't
know that mm-hmm put them on game david
so it just goes
that's it
that's it
nick's specialty and you can find
every sundays at 12 p.m
see you guys next time